soumis les évacuations civiles ont
commencé peu après 10h heure locale des
dizaines de bus ont quitté la ville
direction l'opposition à 150 km à l'est
les habitants étaient prisonniers des
bombardements depuis déjà plusieurs
jours dans morneau propos chat au régime
utilise à mars en top model that i
holdings à
kinshasa
obama propose sheraton alger où pêcher
des corridors humanitaires dont la
trajectoire a été convenu ce matin
concernent également les villes de kiev
marioupol rare qu'yves et tchernihiv il
devrait permettre l'évacuation des
civils vers d'autres villes ukrainiennes
mais en fin matinée les autorités
ukrainiennes ont accusé moscou de
bombarder les civils à la sortie de
marioupol toujours et bara tall a perdu
et batterie douze bateaux de secret
story en roumanie tard lors de la
pratique ou dans les médias ou made you
palais venait nespresso si
le jazz
depuis vendredi le kremlin a promis
plusieurs cessez-le-feu qui n'ont pas
été respectées lundi moscou avait
proposé d'évacuer les civils ukrainien
vers la russie et sa fidèle allié la
biélorussie proposition jugée
inacceptable par tiers
dont les zones de combat les civils
continuent à fuir comme ils peuvent
comme ici à irvine dernière ville verrou
avant kiev une planche de bois glissante
à demi immergé dans l'eau glacée a fait
office de porte de sortie pour dix mille
personnes ces derniers jours ce sont
déjà plus de 2 millions de craignent un
qui ont fui le pays depuis le début de
l'offensive russe il ya 13 jours